hallöchen meine lieben Freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
Folge der Minecraft facts heute am
Dienstag und ich glaube mir atmet hier
irgendwie schon so eine Kuh die ganze
Zeit in Nacken die ist auch relativ laut
dies was ich eigentlich sagen wollte ist
dass ich ein bisschen ko bin ich hatte
gerade 5000 Stunden Uni und BWL und
Wirtschaftsmathematik und alles möglich
und ich bin total fertig aber hey heute
müssen ja noch Minecraft facts kommen
und ich habe mir wieder fünf coole facts
rausgesucht ich hoffe dass die noch
nicht kanntet und dass euch die Folge
gefallen wird aber das kann ich ja
natürlich nicht bestimmen sondern ihr
ich hoffe dass ihr wieder bis zum Ende
dran bleibt weil wirklich wieder coole
facts am Start sind
und ein erster fact los und BAM der
erste fact wurde mir nämlich zugesendet
von mein G und zwar ich hoffe ich SPR
das richtig aus und zwar meint mein G jo
nimm dir doch einfach mal ein Amboss
setz den einfach mal dahin und Pack da
doch einfach mal ein Namenschild rein
und jetzt wie können wir den so ein Tier
nennen so ein Hund ich glaube wenn ich
ein Hund hätte würde ich ihn immer noch
Paddington nennen weil ich finde den
Namen Paddington für ein Tier einfach
extrem cool also jetzt haben wir den
Namen Paddington nehmen hier jetzt den
Wolf erschaffen einen Wolf machen dass
der uns gehört mit den Knochen und jetzt
kommt er uns ja hinterher und alles
mögliche und so weiter und so fort aber
jetzt nehmen wir mal das Namensschild
geben ihm dieses Namensschild und jetzt
heißt der Hund padingon das ist ja schon
mE eine super Sache und jetzt habe ich
hier so ein kleines lavecken und wenn
der Paddington jetzt mal hier hinkommen
würde Paddington komm zum lavabcken los
Paddington wir wollen doch nur Baden P
Paddington du sollst
pington komm komm komm komm komm ich Sch
jetzt einfach mal rein peningon so ein
bisschen Baden hier ne so zack zack zack
zack zack zack zack zack zack zack tot
und ihr seht schon unten eigentlich
sieht man nie bei Tieren auch nicht wenn
ich einen Schwein benenne oder so wenn
da wenn das Tier letztendlich stirbt
allerdings wenn man einen Hund gezähmt
hat und mit einem Namenschild am Start
hat dann steht i Paddington versucht in
Lava zu schwimmen oder Paddington starb
an einem Skelett oder Paddington wurde
abgeschossen oder Paddington viel a so
groß was ist denn los mit diesem
Lavabecken aber ich glaube ihr wisst was
ich meine und das finde ich auf jeden
Fall richtig richtig cool dass man dann
quasi sieht wenn man wirklich ein Hund
hat der einem selbst gehört hör den man
umbenannt hat dass man wirklich erkennt
oh jetzt ist er tot zweite fact
wurde mir zugesandt von Michel und zwar
meint Michel ich soll h einfach mal so
ein Beacon Block machen und dann kommt
ja dieser Strahl raus mit dem
beaconblock kann ich den so Sachen
machen wie Schnelligkeit Elite
Sprungkraft Resistenz Stärke alles
mögliche und dann kann ich hier ganz
noral hoch guucken und se dass da der
beenblock hingeht ich kann da auch
reingehen allerdings wenn ich jetzt mal
genau hier reingehe und hoch Fliege seht
ihr schon ab ein bestimmten Anzahl von
Blöcken also irgendwie zwei drei Blöcke
irgendwie so auf dieser Höhe oder so
geht dieser been Block nicht mehr
wirklich in die Höhe ihr seht der
verschwindet hier immer auf einer
gewissen Stelle immer mal so ein
bisschen auch wenn ich hier direkt neben
stehe und jetzt hier hoch gucke ist er
einfach ab okay direkt daneben jetzt
vielleicht nicht ach ich bin z weit
unten daran liegt dann verschwindet der
einfach ab ein Höhe irgendwann kommt er
dann mal wieder und so das ist dann
alles noch so ein bisschen verpackt ich
weiß nicht genau woran das liegt ob da
die Entwickler eventuell ein bisschen
hält ich weiß nicht ob das oder das
einfach ein ganz normaler lichtbug ist
den man echt mittlerweile echt relativ
häufig hat in Minecraft auch bei Fackeln
mit dem Shader und alles mögliche
allerdings wenn ich hier drin stehe und
ganz normal nach oben gucke ist alles
chillig und wenn ich dann ein bisschen
hoch Fliege seht ihr schon zack ab hier
verschwindet der CA wenn ich da so ein
bisschen hoch gucke dann ist immer so
ein bisschen verpackt und das hat der
Michel rausgefunden danke an dich Michel
und ich finde das sieht hier irgendwie
sehr schön aus dieser Höhle und so ist
eigentlich Lava drin oder
warum wieso ist denn das hier drin so ah
wegen der Ehrlichkeit ich Volltrottel
ich weiß nicht ob ihr den seed besondert
findet aber ich finde immer so ses
einfach richtig cool und dieser se
gefällt mir also da habt ihr den seed
von dieser Welt und man SP genau hier
und die Welt ist eigentlich echt cool
also ich habe so ein Top F seeds Video
gemacht aber ich weiß nicht dies ist vom
Terrain V hier hin so ganz ganz schellig
ne aber egal kommen wir zu fact Nummer 3
fact Nummer 3 wurde mir nämich zugesandt
von Leon und zwar mein Leon Steuerung
plus mittlere Maustaste wirkt außerdem
bei Sachen wie Schild oder im Ofen etc
pp also alle Items die man irgendwie
setzen und verändern kann jetzt nicht
SAS wie ein Leuchtfeuer also natürlich
da greift man halt drauf zu mehr oder
weniger aber man kann das ganze nicht
verändern genauso wie ein crafting table
wenn man da aus dem crafting table
rausgeht fallen die Sachen ja
selbstverständlich raus allerdings ich
hatte das schon mal gezeigt mit einer
Kiste dass man den Inhalt einer Kiste
mitnehmen kann indem man nicht nur die
mittlere Maustaste benutzt zum
Kreativmodus sondern in addition dazu
auch noch die Steuerungstaste und das
gleiche geht mit einem Schild also wenn
ich hier auf das Schild high drauf
schreibe und ich packe jetzt mal das
Schild aus meinem Inventar raus und ich
nehme nur die mittlere Maustaste dann
bekomme ich ein Schild wo nichts drauf
steht wenn ich allerdings ein ganz ganz
langen Text geschrieben habe kann ich
einfach Steuerung drücken das seht ihr
jetzt ganz gut weil ich Optifine drin
hab dass ich wirklich Steuerung gedrückt
halte weil das bei mir auch die
Zoomtaste ist sprinten ist bei mir auf
alt jedenfalls kann ich jetzt die
mittlere Maustaste drücken ihr seht ich
habe ein Schild und da steht auch high
drauf genau das gleiche funktioniert do
bei einem Ofen ich kann den einfach mal
hinsetzen undter 13 Kohle reinpacken
wenn ich den jetzt hier wieder rausnehme
so zack habe ich hier ein Ofen und da
ist nichts drin wenn ich allerdings
dabei Steuerung gedrückt halte so seht
ihr schon hier im Inventar Dekoration
plus NBT also plus die Sachen die da
drin sind bzw was daran verändert wurde
das seht ihr auch beim Schild oder bei
einer Kiste könnt einfach hinsetzen und
da sind die 13 Kohle drin und ich glaube
ich habe wi sehr sehr schnell geredet
das tut mir sehr se
Leid vi vi
vi ach Conny dein Humor ist echt so
scheiße geworden Mann kleiner Wche mach
bessere Videos lad mir hoch der vierte
Fake ist eine Sache die mir mal wieder
selbst aufgefallen ist bzw Minecraft
Forum auch bestätigt stand und zwar seht
ihr schon dass ich gerade hoch Fliege
und ihr seht ja da XY Z auf der linken
Seite wenn ich F3 aktiviert habe und bei
y fliege ich jetzt einfach mal so auf
die Höhe 300 bis 370 so um den Dreh weil
man das da ganz gut sehen kann einfach
immer in Richtung Sonne ihr seht schon
ich schaue immer zur Sonne und dann kann
man nämlich gut erkennen dass Sonne und
Mond immer direkt gegenüber liegen also
ihr seht da ist der Mond da ist die
Sonne die unterscheiden sich so ein
bisschen der hat ein bisschen kühleres
blaues Licht und die Sonne hat ein eher
helleres Licht und wenn jetzt
beispielsweise mal time
Set nein night night eingebe dann seht
ihr schon da ist der Mond und da ist die
Sonne wenn ich jetzt F5 drücke zeige ich
euch gleich weil das ist schon der
fünfte F ich Bagge immer hier so ein
bisschen rum wenn ich mich so angucke
guck mal me meine Hand die beleuchtet
sich mal ganz kurz ein bisschen komisch
aber ihr seht schon die Sonne geht
runter der Mond geht hoch also es ist
nicht irgendwie so wenn man hier nach
ganz unten geht oder so mal schauen
ungefähr wenn das so auf einer Höhe ist
das das ganze nicht so da also es
ist nicht so dass der Mond irgendwie
erst dann auftucht wenn der irgendwie
dann da unten hoch kommt und die Sonne
geht erst dann unter wenn die wirklich
und dann ist sie komplett verschwunden
sondern es ist wirklich so so ein paar
Universum Astrologie Elemente sind schon
vorhanden dass sich das Ganze immer in
einem Zyklus befindet obwohl es ja
eigentlich in der Astrologie so ist dass
der Mond sich um die Erde dreht und der
alles Mögliche um die Sonne und die
Sonne der Mittelpunkt ist aber es ist
egal es ist Minecraft das soll man nicht
so ernst jedenfalls zwischen Höhe 300
und 370 kann man das ganz gut beobachten
dass hier die Sonne ist und da der Mond
und sind immer am böscheln so zusammen
he und das war FEK Nummer vi
ja fact Nummer 5 hat ebenfalls etwas mit
dem Universum hier zu tun und zwar
befinde ich mich gerade wenn ich mal F3
und F1 drücke hier auf Höhe 244 wenn ich
jetzt allerdings mal auf die Höhe 257 in
etwa Fliege also in etwa hier und jetzt
noch ein zwei Blöcke hoch Fliege
verschwinde ich auf einmal achtet mal
auf Y und auf meine Person hier so zack
ich bin weg ich weiß nicht wo ich bin
ich kann auch F5 drücken und meine Hand
ist zwar noch da aber wenn ich wieder F5
drücke hier zack wenn ich so gucke da
bin ich wenn ich dann allerdings so
mache bin ich weg ich verstehe nicht
woran das liegt dass das irgendwie wenn
ich so F Drucken auf einer Geraden Ebene
bin dass dann einfach weg bin ich weiß
nicht genau woran es liegt eventuell
guck mal ich habe ein roten Punkt auf
den und bin ich wieder bin ich wieder
weg bin ich wieder bin ich wieder weg
ich denke ihr wisst oder versteht was
ich euch hiermit irgendwie zeigen möchte
ich verstehe das Ganze nämlich nicht so
ganz warum das ganze so ist eventuell
könnt ihr das in die Kommentare
schreiben ich zeige euch einfach nur das
ganze ist ein fact das ganze ich weiß
nicht woran es liegt aber es ist auf
jeden Fall so und wenn ich dann wieder
ein bisschen runtergehe auf
beispielsweise 255 funktioniert hier
wieder alles vollkommen perfekt aber
wenn ich halt wirklich so ein bisschen
höher Fliege hier dann kann ich mich
halt nur noch sehen wenn ich so nach
oben gucke bisschen komische Sache
wahrscheinlich kennt jeder von euch ich
kann es nicht deswegen habe ich mit in
die Folge genommen und ich würde sagen
das war's auch schon wieder mit dem
Minecraft wenn es euch gefallen hat
würde ich mich sehr sehr doll bei eine
Bewertung freuen und gegen die ganzen
Hater vorzugehen die meinen e bla bla du
ich kannte schon alles was los
l ich h auf orthopädische Schuhe ja das
wird mich auf jeden Fall sehr freuen und
dann würde ich sagen sehen wir uns in
der nächsten Folge der Minecraft am
Freitag wieder und ja
tschüs